en pleurs l'étude et pif art la semaine
dernière encore à confirmer le caractère
exceptionnel de la protection conférée
par le vaccin vis-à-vis des formes
graves nous devons continuer à en
profiter et faire en sorte que
l'immunité reste solide dans la durée
notamment pour les plus âgés et les plus
fragiles nous devons donc accélérer la
campagne de rappel et je lance à nouveau
aujourd'hui mon appel au rappel un appel
à destination de tous nos concitoyens
âgés fragiles qui n'ont pas encore
procédé à leur appel je rappelle qu'il
ya aujourd'hui six millions de français
qui sont éligibles au rappel vaccinal je
mets de côté les soignants six millions
de personnes de plus de 65 ans aux
clients une fragilité importante
vis-à-vis du virus est qu'aujourd'hui
2,1 millions d'entre eux ont reçu leur
appel cela fait près de 4 millions de
personnes éligibles qui n'ont pas encore
reçu leur rappel depuis une dizaine de
jours la campagne de rappel connaît une
légère accélération et nous placent
d'ailleurs en tête des pays européens en
la matière mais elle demeure
insuffisante au vu des enjeux à peine un
tiers du public éligible qui a eu
recours c'est trop peu nous devons le
marteler la protection efficace conférée
par les deux premières doses peut
s'atténuer sensiblement au bout de six
mois c'est la durée qui a été estimée
par les scientifiques retardé son rappel
c'est s'exposer inutilement cette
troisième dose constitue une protection
efficace et surtout indispensable au
moment où l'hiver pourrait faire
repartir la circulation du virus nous
appelons donc chaque médecin chaque
pharmacien chaque professionnel de sens
de santé à sensibiliser ses patients
mais aussi chaque citoyen à sensibiliser
ses proches qui sont concernés pour que
l'ensemble des personnes concernées
puissent être protégés dans la durée se
rappelle qu'au vide peut aussi je le dis
à nouveau se faire en même temps que la
vaccination contre la grippe c'est la
raison pour laquelle olivier ferrand a
annoncé qu'il avançait de quelques jours
le début de la campagne de vaccination
antigrippale puisque un certain nombre
de français âgés attendait le vaccin
contre la grippe pour faire les deux
vaccins en même temps le vaccin contre
la grippe et le rappelle qu vide et donc
la campagne de vaccination antigrippale
démarrera ce vendredi c'est l'occasion
donc pour les français concernés d'aller
se protéger encore une fois chez leur
médecin chez leur pharmacien ou
s'agissant du rappel vaccinal en centre
de vaccination alors pour les personnes
de plus de 65 ans pour les personnes
fragiles je le dis à nouveau procéder à
votre rappel vaccinal
en matière de santé nous souhaitons
rappeler rattraper le passé et préparer
l'avenir c'est là toute l'ambition du
ségur de la santé adoptée il y a un an
et dont le premier ministre a lancé hier
le déploiement du volet investissement
et sur lequel le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé a fait une
communication ce matin en conseil des
ministres le ségur c'est un
investissement historique pour notre
hôpital c'est une volonté et des moyens
colossaux pour notre système hospitalier
et notre système de soins 19 milliards
d'euros seront consacrés pendant dix ans
à la rénovation à l'équipement et à la
numérisation des services des hôpitaux
et des ehpad dans notre pays 19
milliards ce sont 9 milliards pour les
établissements de santé des grands
projets jusqu aux investissements du
quotidien ce sont 6 milliards et demi
pour le désendettement de nos hôpitaux
ce sont deux milliards pour la
modernisation numérique et un milliard
et demi pour les ehpad cette ambition se
déclinera dans chaque région selon les
besoins selon les projets locaux selon
les priorités de chaque territoire il
s'agira notamment de répondre aux défis
de la couverture médicale de l'accès aux
soins en matière de santé mentale de
traitement des cancers ou encore à la
question du vieillissement de notre
population
au total ce volet du ségur bénéficiera à
3000 établissements de santé dont les
trois quarts sont des établissements de
petite taille et de proximité sur
l'ensemble du territoire ce plan
d'investissement est une deuxième étape
historique massive du secteur de la
santé elle fait suite à l'augmentation
inédite massive des salaires permise par
le premier volet du ségur elle s'inscrit
dans la continuité de nos actions pour
renforcer sans cesse la qualité de la
prise en charge et des soins reçus par
nos concitoyens et sur cette question de
la prise en charge en profite pour
rappeler le lancement de
l'expérimentation du numéro unique
d'urgence le 112 annoncé par le
président de la république la semaine
dernier un congrès national des sapeurs
pompiers
cette semaine marque également le
lancement par le président de la
république des états généraux de la
justice depuis le début du quinquennat
nous avons placé la justice au coeur de
notre action nous sommes en effet
convaincus que la question judiciaire
est à l'origine d'une grande part d
insécurité des difficultés et des
ressentiments de nombre de nos
concitoyens c'est pour cela que nous
avons massivement investi et
méthodiquement réformer pour être à la
hauteur de l'exigence républicaine de
bonne administration de la justice le
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti a d'ailleurs présenté ce matin
un bilan de notre action depuis le début
du mandat en premier lieu nous avons mis
fin à des décennies de paupérisation de
la justice ce quinquennat c'est en effet
une hausse de 33 % du budget de la
justice c'est historique entre le début
et la fin de ce quinquennat + 33 % de
budget pour notre système judiciaire ça
n'avait jamais été connu une telle
hausse aussi rapide dans notre pays ce
sont 700 magistrats supplémentaires 850
greffier embaucher et un plan de
construction de 15000 places de prison
mais au delà de ses moyens massifs nous
agissons aussi pour faciliter l'accès
aux droits de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens cela passe par le
déploiement de la procédure pénale
numérique dont le déploiement a commencé
il ya un an après une expérimentation
réussie à ce jour 26 juridiction
reçoivent stocks signe et transmettre
électroniquement les actes des tribunaux
correctionnels
c'est quatre fois plus qu'en janvier
dernier 113 juridiction reçoivent de
manière dématérialisée les procédures
sans auteurs identifiés elles n'étaient
que 6 en janvier dernier cela passe
aussi par l'expérimentation d'un thé les
services de l'aide juridictionnelle qui
divise déjà par trois les délais de
traitement des demandes cela passe enfin
par une justice qui va vers les français
en plus des renforts d'effectifs inédit
accordée aux tribunaux judiciaires nous
avons fait en sorte que la justice
puisse être rendue partout sur notre
territoire hors des murs des tribunaux
judiciaires à proximité directe des
français le nombre de sites hors les
murs des sites dédiés à ces audiences
foraines comme on les appelle a augmenté
de 50 ressent on compte près de 500 de
ces lieux dans toute la france et près
de 10 mille décisions sont rendus chaque
mois hors des tribunaux enfin l'accès au
droit ne doit jamais être un luxe et
nous avons lancé en septembre un numéro
unique d'accès au droit le 30 39 pour
que chacun puisse être conseillé et
accompagné dans ses démarches nous avons
pris à bras le corps des réformes
longtemps repoussée comme celle de la
justice pénale des mineurs la loi sur
les violences sexuelles ou le projet de
loi confiance qui instaure
l'autorisation de filmer les audiences
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour que les
peines soient suivies d'effets mais
aussi que les peines soient adaptés
qu'elles permettent la réinsertion des
condamnés c'est pourquoi nous avons
considérablement développé les travaux
d'intérêt général notamment avec la
création d'une plateforme qui permet à
tous les acteurs de la justice un suivi
précis de l'exécution des travaux
d'intérêt général en organisant ces
états généraux le président a souhaité
réunir la grande famille judiciaire avec
l'implication des citoyens pour
construire un meilleur système
judiciaire nous avons toujours dit que
nous agirions jusqu'au dernier quart
d'heure y compris pour préparer la
france 2 dans dix ans et nous le faisons
une fois encore en matière judiciaire
dans la continuité de ce que nous avons
engagées dans le cadre du beauvau de la
sécurité les magistrats eux-mêmes nous
le disent la perte de confiance de nos
concitoyens dans leur justice est une
préoccupation majeure à laquelle nous
voulons répondre sans délai c'est
pourquoi notre première priorité sera de
bâtir une justice plus proche de nos
concitoyens de leurs préoccupations de
leurs attentes ce qui passera par une
réaffirmation du pacte justice
population c'est la condition même de la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
nous devons donc agir garantir
l'indépendance pour renforcer
l'efficacité mais aussi pour adapter la
justice aux grandes évolutions de notre
société la deuxième grande priorité sera
comme l'a dit le président de la
république de renforcer le service
public de la justice cela veut dire très
concrètement améliorer l'expérience
quotidienne de la justice que vivent nos
concitoyens cela veut dire réduire les
délais de jugement garantir
l'effectivité des peines levée des
contraintes tempéré l'inflation
normative et n'exclure aucune piste de
simplification et de modernisation pour
notre système judiciaire cela veut dire
rendre notre justice plus accessible
cela veut dire enfin décloisonner et
accroître son ouverture sur la société
nous en sommes convaincu la justice est
le fondement est le ciment de notre
pacte social il améliorer au quotidien
c'est tenir et faire vivre la promesse
républicaine
faire vivre la promesse républicaine
c'est aussi mettre en échec ce qui la
combattent et vous avez l'habitude de
m'entendre en compte rendu du conseil
des ministres intervenir sur ce point et
vous faire des annonces ceux qui se
cachent ceux qui dévoient les intentions
nobles pour promouvoir la haine et la
discrimination nous devons les combattre
c'est pourquoi nous avons ce matin en
conseil des ministres a adopté un décret
qui permet la dissolution d'une
association dite coordination contre le
racisme et l'islamophobie association
basé dans le rhône qui était à l'origine
de discours de haine et de propos
antisémites
mesdames et messieurs ce conseil des
ministres a également été l'occasion
d'adopter deux textes tout d'abord la
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion professionnelle et la
ministre de la culture ont présenté un
projet de loi ratifiant une ordonnance
relative aux mesures de protection des
revenus des techniciens et intermittents
du spectacle et de l'audiovisuel
au vu de leur très forte exposition aux
conséquences de la crise nous avions
décidé à plusieurs reprises depuis le
mois d'avril 2020 de prolonger le
dispositif d'année blanche dont
bénéficient des intermittents cette
décision leur a permis de maintenir
leurs droits à l'assurance chômage
depuis le début de la pandémie et cette
ordonnance prolonge de nouveau ses
droits jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 au 1er
janvier 2022 nous avons prévu une sortie
aménagée de l'année blanche qui
maintiendra un soutien davantage ciblées
sur ceux qui n'auraient pas encore
reconstitué leurs droits il n'y a pas un
pays qui a aidé la culture autant que
nous l'avons fait dans le cadre de cette
crise et nous pouvons le dire nous avons
fait vivre l'exception culturelle en
actes dans le cadre de cette crise enfin
le ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation a présenté une ordonnance
renforçant la surveillance et la
prévention des maladies a mal
transmissibles elle organise notamment
la répartition de ses missions
essentielles entre l'union européenne
l'état les opérateurs et les
professionnels prévoient également de
rénover le système d'identification et
de traçabilité animal d'ici à 2024 voilà
mesdames messieurs ce que je pouvais
vous dire de ce conseil des ministres et
je me tiens maintenant à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
bonjour monsieur ministre s'amuse taxi
pour canal+ ces news vous n'avez pas
évoqué la question de l'énergie
on nous explique que le premier ministre
doit s'exprimer de façon imminente
aujourd'hui au maximum demain à ce que
d'abord vous confirmer cette information
et puis par ailleurs bercy bruno le
maire aurait proposé une troisième voie
aux autres que le chèque énergie et que
la baisse des taxes qu'elle tuerait à
7,3 boîte vous l'a confirmé ce que vous
pouvez tout simplement nous en dire plus
et nous dire là la piste privilégiée
merci
il ya une demande très forte en matière
d'énergie partout dans le monde qui est
principalement liée à la reprise
économique et nous savons c'est la loi
du marché quand vous avez une demande
forte qui augmente et une offre qui ne
l'augmentent pas les prix augmentent et
donc tous les pays dans le monde sont
confrontés à cette hausse des prix de
l'énergie depuis le début de cette crise
on a pris des mesures très tôt on a pris
des mesures sur la question des tarifs
du gaz avec un blocage des prix qui
avait été annoncé par le premier
ministre ce qui fait que les hausses de
30 40 % qui était prévu d'ici à la fin
de l'année n'auront pas lieu on a
annoncé des mesures sur le prix de
l'électricité ce qui fait que les os ce
qui était prévu de l'ordre de 13 voire
15% pour les tarifs de l'électricité au
début de l'année n'auront pas lieu une
mesure fiscale a été prise elle a
d'ailleurs été adopté dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances pour contraint
dé contenir cette hausse il ya la
question du carburant moi je suis
parfaitement conscient et nous sommes
parfaitement conscients que pour
beaucoup de français il s'agit d'une
dépense contrainte que pour beaucoup de
français c'est une dépense contrainte
alors même qu'ils doivent se déplacer
pour aller travailler et que bien
souvent leur rémunération ne leur permet
pas facilement de boucler leurs fins de
mois c'est un euphémisme beaucoup de
français qui travaillent ont du mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois et c'est pour
eux que nous avons agi depuis le début
de ce quinquennat avec des mesures pour
revaloriser la prime d'activité pour
défiscaliser les heures supplémentaires
pour exonérer de charges sociales pour
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu pour
permettre le versement de primes les
primes macron par les entreprises bref
nous avons à travers ces mesures permis
de donner un 13e mois et un quasi de 14e
mois aux français qui travaille au smic
est ce que ne voulons pas c'est que les
hausses des prix de l'énergie et
notamment du carburant viennent animer
tous ses efforts ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui mais force est de constater
que ces hausses grignote ses efforts et
que évidemment nous voulons continuer à
protéger les français et notamment les
français qui travaillent qui travaille
dur et qui prennent de plein fouet ses
os et donc il ya un travail qui a été
engagée et des mesures qui vont être
annoncés dans les tout prochains jours
par le gouvernement je me suis exprimé
hier sur une radio j'ai indiqué que ce
serait d'ici la fin de la semaine ce
sera dans les tout prochains jours ça
sera annoncée par le gouvernement il ya
plusieurs pistes qui sont à l'étude j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire qu'aucune piste
n'était exclue je vais pas vous dire ici
quelle est la non ce qui va être faite
puisque les derniers arbitrages sont en
cours mais évidemment
mesure parfaitement l'impatience la
volonté que les mesures puissent être
annoncés plus rapidement possible
évidemment que pour nous il faut que
cette annonce est que ces mesures soient
simples lisibles efficaces qu'elles
permettent d'accompagner les français
qui sont les plus exposés vis-à-vis de
ces hausses qui ont le plus de mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois qu'elle soit
encore une fois simple s'agit pas
d'inventer une usine à gaz il faut que
ça soit simple et c'est tout le travail
qui a été mené sous l'égide du premier
ministre ces derniers jours il ya
plusieurs réunions qui ont eu lieu entre
membres du gouvernement sur ce sujet et
encore une fois les annonces
interviendront dans les tout prochains
jours
bonjour marie chanterait pour tf1 et
c'est une question sur le volet
sanitaire vous avez exclu il ya deux
semaines tout allègement du pass
sanitaire avant le 15 novembre prochain
pensez-vous aujourd'hui une évolution du
pass est envisageable au 15 novembre
déjà première question et deuxième
question vous avez battu le rappel pour
la troisième dose le rappelle la dose de
rappel pour les 65 ans et plus est ce
que cette troisième dose pourrait
conditionner l'obtention du pass
sanitaires merci beaucoup alors pour la
première question je ne je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui comment une adaptation du
pass sanitaires pour intervenir au 15
novembre j'avais effectivement été
interrogé et quelques semaines j'avais
dit qu'en tout état de cause si la
question devait se poser ce sera à
partir du 15 novembre aujourd'hui vu la
situation je ne vois pas comment une
adaptation pourrait intervenir au 15
novembre il ya une reprise de l'épidémie
constate à peu près partout en europe
encore une fois en allemagne aux
pays-bas en belgique une reprise très
forte et préoccupante en europe de l'est
si on va encore un peu plus loin en
russie je crois qu'on atteint des
sommets en termes de nombre de
contaminations et de décès au royaume
uni cette situation très préoccupante
aussi cette situation cette reprise qui
est probablement liée en grande partie
aux conditions hivernales et au fait que
le virus circule davantage dans ces
conditions nous le savons
malheureusement désormais à entraîner
d'ailleurs à certains pays à prendre des
mesures je pense notamment à la lettonie
qui a annoncé un recond finement avec
fermeture des écoles pour quatre
semaines du fait de la hausse très forte
de l'épidémie il se trouve que dans ce
pays comme dans d'autres pays notamment
à l'est de l'europe il ya une donnée
heureusement que nous n'avons pas en
france c'est une faible couverture
maximale vaccinale je crois que en
lettonie c'est autour de 50% de la
population qui est protégé par le vaccin
on est nettement au-dessus en france et
c'est grâce à ça notamment que lorsqu'il
ya eu la quatrième vague nous n'avons
pas eu à reprendre des mesures aussi
parce que nous avons des outils et
notamment le pass sanitaire qui
permettent de réduire la circulation du
virus qui permettent aussi d'inciter à
la vaccination est évidemment il faut
qu'on puisse continuer à utiliser ses
outils autant que c'est nécessaire
maintenant on a toujours montré que dès
lors qu'on peut adapter des outils voire
se débarrasser de mesures quand c'est
possible on le fait on a fait des
adaptations notamment sur le port du
masque dans un certain nombre de
départements pour les enfants à l'école
dès que c'est possible on le fait et
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas comment ça
serait le cas au 15 novembre je le dis
de manière très transparente sur la
deuxième question que vous avez posé
c'est à dire celle pour le public qui
est éligible c'est-à-dire notamment les
plus de 65 ans de l'intégration de la
troisième dose ou du rappel vaccinal
dans le pass sanitaires c'est une piste
qui fait son chemin sans qu'aucune
décision n'a été prise à ce stade comme
a eu l'occasion de le dire le premier
minis ce qui guidera l'éventuelle
décision en ce sens c'est bien l'avis la
recommandation des autorités sanitaires
bonjour monsieur le ministre on vous a
entendu parler de justice en préambule
alors justement une question sur le
rapport sauvé y ait eu très peu de
parole politique sur les suites à donner
à ce rapport en matière de police et de
justice pourquoi est ce que les
dispositifs mis en place pour les
violences faites aux femmes ne sont pas
utilisés pour les victimes de prêtres
pédophiles
avez vous prévu d' inciter les victimes
à parler pour donner des suites
judiciaires à cette dizaine voir ces
centaines de milliers d'agressions
sexuelles dont une grande partie sont
précises ne sont pas prescrites puisque
certains faits sont très récents je
remercie évidemment que vous savez vous
le savez et surtout les faits de
violence évidemment aussi les violences
sexuelles nous invitons évidemment si
les victimes à parler saisir les
autorités judiciaires c'est le cas
depuis le début de ce quinquennat les
conclusions du rapport sauvé sont
édifiantes effarante nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer mais une
nouvelle fois je voulais dire deux
choses sur ce sujet d'abord que
lorsqu'on parle de ce sujet on pense et
on doit d'abord témoigner d'une pensée
pour les victimes pour leur famille
c'est toujours important de le rappeler
et la deuxième chose c'est salué aussi
l'esprit de responsabilité qui a mené à
cette mission confiée à jean marc sauvé
et à ce rapport et ça il faut aussi le
dire c'est pour ça que nous prenons
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour que
la parole se libère pour identifier les
responsables pour obtenir justice et
permettre la reconstruction le rapport
sauvé a travaillé sur les victimes
d'actes commis dans le cadre de l'église
nous avons de notre côté évidemment au
niveau du gouvernement de l'état agit
nous avons mis en place en début d'année
une commission la commission
indépendante sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
qui travaillent sur les violences
sexuelles subies par les enfants pour
venir en aide à toutes les victimes à la
fois dans le cadre familial mais aussi
évidemment plus largement dans d'autres
cadres je pense au milieu du sport et
plus globalement aux accueils collectifs
de mineurs c'est une commission qui est
dirigé par
edouard durand qui est un juge pour
enfants et nathalie mathieu
qu'irresponsable atouts associative nous
avons doté cette commission de 4
millions d'euros elle a une feuille de
route sur deux ans pour entendre récolté
les témoignages d'un maximum de victimes
mais pour faire des propositions bien
sûr je le redis nous n'avons pas attendu
depuis le début du quinquennat nous
avons agi sur ce sujet je pense aux
visites de dépistage des violences pour
tous les enfants en primaire et au
collège je pense à un meilleur recueil
de la parole et la mise en place d'un
parcours de soins adaptés une unité par
département dès l'an prochain je pense à
la formation de tous les professionnels
en contact avec des enfants je pense
enfin et on se souvient que c'est une
mesure qui avait été très relayée très
commentée à l'inscription systématique
aux fichiers des agresseurs sexuels lefa
mieux le fameux fille ges des personnes
consultant des images
pédopornographiques et à celles
coupables d'exhibition sexuelle vous
voyez qu'il ya une mobilisation depuis
le début de ce quinquennat que par
ailleurs il ya une commission
indépendante qui a été mise en place qui
est doté d'un budget qui est animé par
des personnes qui connaissent
parfaitement ce sujet là et qui doit non
seulement agir permettre de recueillir
la parole mais aussi formuler des
propositions
les victimes à parler mais depuis le
début de ce quinquennat un numéro comme
ça a été fait pour les violences faites
aux femmes c'est envisagé je crois qu'il
existe des dispositifs
téléphoniques et des plates formes qui
permettent de recueillir la parole mais
encore une fois s'il faut mieux
communiquer autour de ces dispositifs je
retiens est évidemment nous allons
continuer à le faire
france télévisions sur le revenu
d'engagement au départ il était question
que 1 millions de jeunes soit concerné à
l'arrivée ce serait plutôt 500 milles
pourquoi ce plan est moins ambitieux a
priori canon le président la république
s'est exprimé le 12 juillet souvient
dans son allocution sur une mobilisation
encore supplémentaires en faveur des
jeunes je rappelle que le plan à jeanne
une solution qui est déployée depuis le
début de la crise ses 9 milliards
d'euros c'est des millions de jeunes qui
sont accompagnés qui ont pu trouver un
emploi grâce à la prime de 4000 euros
qu'on a mise en place auprès des
entreprises qui recrutent un jeune de
moins de 26 ans en cdi ou en cdd depuis
trois mois des jeunes qui sont en
apprentissage on a un historique
d'apprentissage grâce là aussi à
l'accompagnement financier des jeunes
qui sont en garantie jeunes ont des
parcours d'insertion en service civique
parce que c'est des dispositifs qu'on a
déployé qu'on a renforcé en terme de
budget le président la république s'est
exprimé le 12 juillet dernier pour
annoncer une mobilisation supplémentaire
je veux simplement rappeler qu'il ya pas
de deux chiffres qui avait été donnée à
cette époque il ya des articles de
presse qui font état de pistes de
travail mais il ya pas eu d'annoncés
gouvernementales sur ce sujet là est
donc évidemment le gouvernement continue
à travailler sur ce sujet là dans les
prochaines semaines des annonces seront
faites par le gouvernement je peux pas
vous en dire plus aujourd'hui ni sur le
calendrier ni sur le sens de ces
annonces de même que je ne confirme pas
des articles de presse qui mettait
publiés mais est ce que la conjoncture
économique où il ya une reprise et c
pourrait faire revoir le dispositif mais
encore une fois ce qu'a annoncé le
président c'est un accompagnement
renforcé pour les jeunes c'est vrai
qu'on était le 12 juillet dernier à un
moment où on était dans une phase de
croissance très forte de la quatrième
vague dont on ne savait pas combien de
temps elle allait durer les dégâts
qu'elles pourraient faire sur notre
économie et donc évidemment sur notre
jeunesse qui a été
très impacté par la crise économique qui
a découlé la crise sanitaire depuis le
début de cette pandémie aujourd'hui fort
heureusement nous avons réussi à
contenir cette quatrième vague nous
avons réussi à contenir ses effets sur
notre économie puisqu'il ya une reprise
une croissance très forte en france
locomotive de la plupart des pays
européens qui est estimé à 6 25% en 2021
qu'on a un taux de chômage qui a très
fortement diminué et je rappe je vous
rappelle les prévisions qui ont été
publiés la semaine dernière qui estime
qu'à la fin de cette année on pourra
être retombé à un niveau qu'on n'avait
pas connu dans notre pays depuis treize
ans que vous avez aujourd'hui énormément
d'entreprises et de secteurs économiques
qui font part de leurs difficultés à
recruter et que donc et que donc
évidemment l'accompagnement qu'on va
apporter aux jeunes il vise à répondre
aux préoccupations et problématiques qui
existe aujourd'hui dans notre pays et
notamment pour les jeunes et donc on
adapte évidemment les choses à la
lumière de la situation et de ce dont
les jeunes ont besoin aujourd'hui c'est
sale
il faut partir des besoins des jeunes
aujourd'hui concrètement au quotidien et
renforcer les dispositifs quand c'est
nécessaire pour les accompagner et c'est
ce qui est travaillé par le gouvernement
ce qui sera annoncé très prochainement
bonjour sylvie corbet société de presse
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où on
en est dans le bras de fer avec les
britanniques et les anglo normand sur
les licences de pêche pour les pêcheurs
français
est-ce que le gouvernement va annoncer
des mesures de rétorsion et si oui à
quelle date elle prendrait effet
d'abord on aimerait ne pas avoir à
annoncer des sanctions parce qu'on
aimerait que les britanniques respecte
l'accord qu'ils ont signé
ils ont signé un accord et ils ont fait
preuve jusqu'à maintenant d'une volonté
manifeste de ne pas respecter cet accord
qui a été signé dans le cadre du
breakbeat de notre côté nous la france
on a toujours produit tous les documents
qui était demandé toutes les
informations qui étaient demandés on a
des pêcheurs et je veux leur rendre
hommage
qui ont fait preuve d'une très grande
patience parce qu'on parle de leur
capacité à travailler et on parle pour
eux d'un interlocuteur qui manifestement
ne veut pas respecter un accord qu'ils
ont signé
et donc il ya un travail qui a été
engagé notamment dans le cadre de la
commission européenne qui est compétente
sur ces sujets là et sur les accords qui
ont été signés annick girardin la
ministre de la mer était reçu vendredi
dernier par le vice président de la
commission européenne elle était
d'ailleurs accompagné
d'organisations professionnelles de
pêcheurs pour faire le point sur ce
sujet là et sur la mobilisation de la
commission européenne qui se poursuit je
rappelle que la france a demandé la
réunion du conseil de partenariat qui
est l'instance prévue par les textes et
par l'accord pour aborder la suite dans
ce type de situation mais j'avais déjà
eu l'occasion de vous dire qu'évidemment
nous nous mettions en situation de
pouvoir prendre des sanctions dès lors
que l'accord ne serait pas respectée il
ya une date qui a été fixée mais qui a
été fixé par jersey même sur la date
butoir pour transmettre les licences à
la france c'est je crois le 30 octobre
et donc c'est au 30 octobre que nous
verrons si jusqu'au bout ils ont décidé
de ne pas respecter l'accord qui a été
signé mais nous nous mettons en
situation de prendre des mesures ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que d'ici à la
fin de la semaine nous souhaitons
annoncé des types de sanctions que nous
prônons que nous pourrions prendre et
pour le calendrier que vous évoquez
c'est les sanctions qui se rêve prise
dans le courant du mois de novembre dès
lors que les délais n'auraient pas été
respectées et que l'accord n'aurait pas
été respecté il ya plusieurs types de
sanctions qui sont possibles sur le
tarif de l'énergie sur l'accès au port
sur des questions douanières d'autres
mesures sont possibles et c'est sur ce
point que communiquerons mes collègues
annick girardin jean yves le drian
clément bonne ici à la fin de la semaine
bonjour laurence mesdames ou de la fp je
voulais revenir sur les questions de mes
confrères et consoeurs d'abord sur le
pass sanitaires vous avez dit que avec
en plus le rebond de l'épidémie vous ne
voyez pas comment l'adapter au 15
novembre est ce que ça signifie que il
vous semble probable souhaitable que le
pas soit prolongé au delà du 15 novembre
pour être clair comme vous l'avez dit
déjà et j'ai une deuxième question sur
le revenu et d'engagement
effectivement c'est la mesure paraît
moins ambitieuse d'après ce que j'ai
compris vous avez aussi une allusion un
lien avec les filières en tension si
j'ai bien compris est ce qu'on pouvait
nous donner expliqué un tout petit peu
ce que vous avez voulu dire par là merci
sur le premier point en matière de lutte
contre l'épidémie
il n'y a pas
ce qui est souhaitable qu est ce qui est
nécessaire ce qui est nécessaire pour
contraindre une flambée épidémique pour
éviter d'avoir une nouvelle vague forte
de circulation du virus dans notre pays
est évidemment qu'elle impacte notre
hôpital et qu'elle entraîne une
saturation nos services hospitaliers
comme on a eu l'occasion malheureusement
de le vivre très douloureusement à
plusieurs reprises dans le cadre de
cette crise ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les outils qui sont nécessaires
efficace utile pour empêcher cette
situation évidemment qu'ils doivent être
mobilisés c'est en ce sens que un texte
de loi est discuté en ce moment même au
parlement pour prolonger des outils
jusqu'à l'été prochain pour que nous
puissions les mobiliser s'il y avait une
reprise épidémique il ne s'agit encore
une fois pas de dire que ces outils
seront nécessairement prononcer
de manière permanente jusqu'à cette date
il s'agit de dire qu'il ya des outils
qui ont fait leur preuve encore une fois
sans le pass sanitaires sans la
vaccination on aura eu à refermer cet
été nos restaurants nos barnaud théâtre
au cinéma on aurait peut-être eu à
prendre des mesures encore plus
difficile au coeur de l'été on n'a pas
eu à le faire grâce à cet outil donc cet
outil évidemment qu'il faut qu'on puisse
le conserver le garder dans la poche
pour pouvoir le réactiver dès lors que
c'est nécessaire et dès lors que ce sera
possible évidemment on l'adaptera moi ce
que j'ai dit simplement par rapport à la
question qui m'a été posée par marie
chanterai c'est que aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas comment il peut être adapté au
15 novembre encore une fois dès lors que
ce sera possible on le fera on n'est ni
fétichiste du pass sanitaires ni
fétichiste du qr codes ni fétichiste des
mesures de contrainte vis-à-vis des
français à chaque fois qu'on a pu
adapter les mesures on l'a fait et
d'ailleurs quand on regarde depuis le
début de cette épidémie à chaque vague
on a adapté notre réponse est la
première vague avec des mesures très
fortes de confinement généralisée il ya
eu la deuxième vague on a pu maintenir
ouvertes nos écoles il ya eu la
troisième vague on a pu avoir des
mesures qui a invité les français à
rester dehors plutôt qu'à rester
confinés chez eux il ya eu la quatrième
vague on a pu maintenir grâce au pass
sanitaires quasiment tous les lieux
ouverts et ils ont pu fonctionner
normalement grâce au pass sanitaire qui
est un outil dont je veux rappeler quand
même que il me semble que les français
ont vu qu'il était extrêmement simple
d'utilisation et y compris les
responsables des établissements recevant
du public qu'ils ont à contrôler le pass
sanitaires il y avait des inquiétudes au
départ j'ai beaucoup échangé cet été
avec des restaurateurs des responsables
de bars sur le pass sanitaire c'est
devenu quelque chose de quand même assez
simple dans le quotidien ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il faut garder advitam eternam
voilà et j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire
que dans x men ou x mois la situation se
sera tellement nettement améliorée et
tellement nettement stabilisées qu'on
pourra l'adapter malheureusement
je ne peux pas vous le dire parce que
cette épidémie malheureusement continue
à surprendre le monde entier avoir une
cinétique que nous ne maîtrisons pas
il y avait marre et chanterait avant à
pardon et sur le revenu non sur le
revenu d'engagement ce que je disais
pour répondre à la question dan bourse
qui m'interrogeait sur le contexte dans
lequel cette mesure avait été annoncée
par rapport au contexte aujourd'hui je
rappelais simplement les faits et le
contexte de l'époque le contexte
aujourd'hui il y a toujours aujourd'hui
nécessité d'accompagner les jeunes pour
ça que les mesures la plupart des
mesures du plan allon une solution qui
était prévu au départ de manière
temporaire ont été prolongées aussi
parce qu'elles ont fait leurs preuves je
pense à la mesure de soutien à
l'apprentissage qui nous permet
aujourd'hui d'atteindre un niveau
exceptionnel de jeunes en apprentissage
dans notre pays ce qui est bon pour les
jeunes ce qui est bon pour les
entreprises qui est bon pour notre
économie donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
prolongé les mesures et c'est pour ça
que des mesures seront annoncées
conformément à ce qu'avait annoncé le
président de la république le 12 juillet
pour renforcer cet accompagnement et
permettre l'insertion et l'emploi des
jeunes dans notre pays c'est quand même
ça notre objectif principal
je crois que marie chantera était avant
je fais juste mais elle vous laisse sa
place à l'équité dans nos échanges juste
peut pas partir trop loin de l'histoire
du pain sanitaire et de la troisième
dose est ce qu'il vous semble possible
avant que à peu près toute la population
soit concerné par par un éventuel dose
de rappel c'est à dire soit six mois
après sa deuxième dose est ce qu'il vous
semble possible de conditionner le
maintien du passé ni terre à ces deux
rappels je formule autrement est-ce que
temps que seulement une partie des
français les plus de 65 ans les plus
fragiles ceux qui souffrent de
pathologies particulières
est ce que si seul cesser ces catégories
de personnes sont concernées on peut
réduire leur usage du passé ni terre
d'abord je dire c'est aujourd'hui le
public qui est concerné par le rappel je
rappelle que je veux dire à nouveau que
c'est les recommandations des agences
sanitaires des scientifiques qui nous
disent qu'il faut que le rappel soit
proposés ils soient réalisées par les
personnes âgées les personnes fragiles
qui sont les plus à risque de l'épidémie
les soignants également
parce qu'elles sont mais aussi par ce
nom parce qu'elles sont les plus
fragiles vis-à-vis d'une forme grave les
personnes de plus de 65 ans du fait de
leur âge ce sont des personnes qui ont
une fragilité particulière vis-à-vis du
virus est encore une fois le vaccin
permet de les protéger de manière
exceptionnelle à 95% des études
scientifiques montrent partout dans le
monde qu'au bout d'un certain nombre de
mois autour de six mois la protection
conférée par le vaccin peut avoir
tendance à diminuer et que donc un
rappel est nécessaire pour maintenir
très haut la protection conférée par la
vaccination c'est pour ça qu'on a engagé
cette campagne de rappel si vous dites
seulement ce public c'est un public
important quand même aujourd'hui c'est 6
millions de personnes si on prend les
personnes de plus de 65 ans et les
personnes malades c'est 6 millions de
personnes c'est un public important
c'est un public qui va continuer à
croître le public éligible puisque vous
l'avez dit c'est six mois après son
parcours vaccinale complet c'est 2-2
qu'on est éligible mais c'est un public
important et aujourd'hui à 33 ou 34 % de
ce public qui a reçu son rappel ce qui
encore une fois est beaucoup c'est
nettement supérieur à la plupart des
pays européens pour qu'on est premier ou
deuxième pays européen en termes de
rappel aujourd'hui mais c'est trop peu
et c'est trop peu notamment face aux
conditions que nous connaissons des
conditions hivernales de circulation
d'autres virus aussi bon pioli tu es
grippe et donc il faut aller plus loin
dans notre campagne de rappel
de questions très différente vous étiez
sans doute en conseil des ministres
lorsque la vidéo est apparue sur les
réseaux sociaux et les télévisions mais
eric zemmour était en visite ce matin à
l'occasion d'un salon militaire il s'est
équipé d'une arme qu'on lui proposait et
à un moment donné il se tourne vers les
journalistes en blaguant 10 ans recule
et marlène schiappa qualifié l'image d'
horrifiantes je voulais savoir ce que
vous inspirez en tant que porte parole
du gouvernement cette séquence enfin je
mangeais l'habitude de commander des
séquences que j'ai vu et vous l'avez dit
j'étais en conseil des ministres et
enfin je veux dire par ailleurs jeu
j'essaye de ne pas passer mon temps
puisque c'est pas mes fonctions de porte
parole du gouvernement a commenté les
faits et gestes des uns et des autres et
en ce moment surtout des 1 maintenant si
vous me demandez à moi porte parole du
gouvernement évidemment dont la mission
est de travailler au quotidien avec vous
si vous demandez à moi qui suis très
attaché à la liberté de la presse au
respect des journalistes dans un
contexte où il ya non seulement
évidemment des menaces très fortes qui
pèsent sur eux dans le monde mais en
plus on l'a vu malheureusement ces
dernières années en france des
agressions parfois de journalistes qui
font leur travail évidemment que je
condamnerai toujours toute menace qui
implique des journalistes mais encore
une fois j'ai pas vu les images auquel
vous faites référence donc c'est une
réponse générique entre guillemets par
rapport à ce que vous me rapportez
politique françois hollande écrit dans
le livre à paraître prochainement
emmanuel macron est un voyageur sans
boussole qu'il est plus caméléon que
bonaparte est ce qu'un ancien président
tu devrais dire ça il me semble rien de
très nouveau françois hollande il nous a
habitués depuis quatre ans à être très
critique vis-à-vis du président de la
république du gouvernement pour des
raisons qui lui appartiennent ce qui me
semble assez nouveau dans la séquence
récente c'est la vigueur de ces attaques
visent à vis de son propre camp ou de
ses propres amis tant et si bien qu'à un
moment on finit par se dire il n'y a pas
grand monde qui trouve grâce aux yeux de
françois hollande si ce n'est françois
hollande après je n'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire sur ce sujet
bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
je vous remercie et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine